does the morning star ever fade away in
the case of Lucifer there's a strong
chance a fallen angel may stay gone for
good Lucifer may be centered on the
literal devil but it's not your average
religious fantasy drama the series is
just something unique mixing in elements
of horror mystery thriller and police
procedural as Lucifer Morning Star helps
out on cases with the Los Angeles Police
Department and runs a successful
nightclub to boot beside Lucifer is
detective Khloe DEA a dedicated cop who
was somehow immune to to his
manipulative powers in addition to
taking on the most Grizzly crimes
Lucifer and deca must contem with deca's
disgruntled ex-husband and fellow
detective Dan and Lucifer's brother a
menadel the angel wants Lucifer to
return back down below and will do
whatever it takes to get him back to
Rolling hell to make things more
complicated though Lucifer's immortality
seems to falter whenever Deca is near
making their already difficult
partnership or the more problematic when
they fall in love over the course of the
series a menad deal is joined by his
mother and the biblical cane among
others who cause Earthly problems for
Lucifer but when Deca discovers
Lucifer's true face she struggles to
accept that she's in love with the devil
in the show's final year Lucifer
actually does the unthinkable attempting
to fill the shoes of God himself or
trying to rescue Dan who is trapped in
hell all while trying to find a new
place for himself in the universe it may
be tempting to assume that Lucifer was
cancelled due to lack of viewership or
cost cutting measures but the truth is
Lucifer ended on its own terms closing
out it's run by the decision of the
series showrunners Joe Henderson and II
modvic who knew when it was time to say
goodbye as Henderson explained to
Entertainment Weekly it's the story we
were always going to tell according to
Henderson the show was almost going to
end after season 5 but it was actually
Netflix who wanted them to return for
one more year as a result the story was
split up into two seasons of 16 and 10
episodes each he said what we realize is
that the last bit of that series finale
episode was actually a lot of great
stories sped up just to give it a
satisfying ending for all of our
characters we literally lobbed off act
six and went let's take what happens in
act six in a scene and dive into it and
really explore how our characters end up
where they ended up so that ended up
being our nugget for season 6 in the end
though the show Runners knew the story
was over whether it was one season or
two they got to tell the story they
wanted and the series ended to their
satisfaction so just think of me as your
guardian devil Lucifer already said
goodbye twice it's in 2018 it was
canceled after just three seasons on Fox
becoming a victim of poor ratings for a
prime time series on a major Network
thankfully Netflix swooped in and
rescued the series giving it three more
seasons and 36 additional episodes much
to the Delight of fans but since it bid
farewell in 2021 there hasn't been so
much as a peep regarding a return for
season 7 as it stands a sixth season
finale was a fitting end for Lucifer and
the series as a whole it ended with
Lucifer becoming a therapist and the
credits role after a brief reunion when
Deca entered his office as the show's
co- show Runners have said this was the
perfect farewell and the lack of a
seventh season at this point is really
no mystery the people behind the show
simply don't seem all that interested in
bringing the cast back for more when
it's so fresh from having ended his
phenomenal run still considering the
series has already survived one ending
it could live to see another season
revivals after years off the air are
nothing new and shows like good Omens
and American Gods have proven there's a
thriving appetite for offbeat stories
about biblical Angels and Demons on
Earth the cast of Lucifer went through a
number of changes during its six seasons
on the air while Tom Ellis and Lauren
German headlined the series for its
entire run as Lucifer and deca
respectively several others came and
went for example Kevin Alejandro DB
Woodside and Leslie and Brandt made it
through all six seasons as detective
Espinosa a menad deal and the demon
mazikin but Kevin Rankin was long gone
by season six the likes of Tom Welling
and Trisha hord both for a onepoint
series regulars Midway through the show
B Brianna Hilder brand was added to the
show in its final year if Lucifer is to
be taken seriously in a potential
seventh season though Ellis and German
will have to reprise their roles at the
very least it's also possible that
Alejandro and hord could return given
how their story was left at the end of
season six meanwhile brand may not
necessarily need to come back but she
could receive her own spin-off while
it's likely that a season 7 would bring
back most of the show's roster of stars
it wouldn't be hard to imagine some new
actors The Ensemble whether that's a new
demon or angel or even another fellow
detective there's plenty of room for
some fresh Talent you're scared I'm
turning my back on the dark side bro
there's plenty to speculate on given
where the finale left all of its
characters including Lucifer himself in
the final installment we see him having
entirely abandoned both his duties as
ruler of hell and his temporary position
as God which is now being performed by
his brother a menal a potential angle
for a continuation might be to flip the
premise on its head by ditching the
police procedural format entirely and
turning the series into more of a
medical procedural even though producers
desire to end the series as it was it
stands the reason they be looking for a
Fresh Approach if they were to bring it
back a notion of the devil incarnate
serving as counsil to patients
struggling with their mental health
could be just a kind of new idea to
allow the show to continue and with his
vast experiences on Earth and Beyond who
better to listen and offer advice in
Lucifer similarly the new roles for The
Supporting Cast offer plenty of
opportunity for continuation with mazak
and even romantic Ally involved in
serving as villain Hunters themselves
meanwhile the continuation of the family
line in the form of a menal son Charlie
could see a new Young demon join the
cast the cast of Lucifer has been mum on
their interest in returning for the
series to date while the show Runners
were happy with how the series concluded
they have added further commentar since
then a year after the series concluded
they seemed at least somewhat open to
thinking about a future for the show
coinciding with the release of Lucifer
on home media they sat down for an
interview with Scream rant in September
202 2 well they were asked about the
possibility of another go Joe Henderson
said I mean I hope so we loved making
the show we loved working with these
people I think hopefully at some point
we can find a way to come back or at
least revisit or do something whether
that means another full season a single
streaming movie or a spin-off it sounds
like Henderson is most excited about
reuniting with his cast and crew no
matter what form it takes he admitted
how the whole experience turned out to
be so wonderful along with the people so
he wouldn't write off the possib ility
entirely of course Eli Mich couldn't
resist a chance of slip in a somewhat
Sly response she said my vote is for
Lucifer the musical personally on
Broadway Henderson followed up
immediately with a sarcastic suggestion
of Lucifer the Animated Series Chloe is
my chin butlike I was just going to say
this amazing in real life sure what fans
really want to see is another full
season of Lucifer or perhaps a form
movie that directly follows season 6 of
the show that being said there may be
opportunities for Tom alist priz his
title role somewhere other than a
traditional Revival for starters he's
already turned up in a cameo in the CW's
crisis on infinite Earth storyline that
included Tyler heckin Superman is it
possible we can see Lucifer back in
action in heckin Superman and Lois it
may seem like a long shot but it's
certainly possible James gun is
assembling an allnew DC Universe of
films though much of it is expected to
be entirely new he's not averse to
bringing in existing characters and
actors as evidenced by the return of his
Peacemaker cast so far he hasn't
recruited anyone from the vast Universe
of television shows but it's certainly
not a hard and fast Rule and we've seen
rival Marvel do that very thing when
they brought Charlie Cox into the MCU
with gun's initial Gods and Monsters
Face of the new DCU putting an emphasis
on the Bazar it could very well require
a devil to oversee the spiritual side of
things if it does gun could recruit
Ellis to fill that role as Lucifer fans
of Lucifer have proven just how
dedicated they are to their favorite
series it was a fan driven effort that
got the series series back from the
brink of Extinction in 2018 when it was
acted by Fox banding together as only
fans can they started a save Lucifer
campaign that burned up social media and
forced Hollywood to take notice
eventually that passionate outpouring of
fan support convinced Netflix to take a
leap of faith and bring the series back
which ultimately led to three successful
follow-up Seasons flash forward to the
show's conclusion on streaming and the
fans were back at it hoping to convince
the powers at B to do it again fans
rallied on change.org the first time but
the petition that garnered an excess of
300,000 signatures to save the show in
2019 fans once again gained more than
19,000 plus supporters to get the show a
sixth season and while several current
petitions on the site have yet to crack
those lofty figures their repeated
appearance has proof enough that fans of
the show aren't to be Overlook a
petition to bring Lucifer and deca back
for Lucifer the movie has amassed
several thousand signatures too these
are sure to be numbers that Netflix is
paying attention to needless to say if
there ever is going to be a season 7 or
continuation of any sort it will be the
fans of the show who will likely be
playing a role in helping make it happen
devil Banes oh no Lucy fans if there is
ever going to be a season 7 of Lucifer
there is a way that it could happen
though the two show winers have jokingly
responded to questions with offers of a
musical and an animated series they also
seem genuinely interested in revisiting
the character at some point down the
line with streaming services also
struggling in recent times the need for
established hits could see Tom Ellis
pulled back into his popular role that's
not the only way we could see a new
season though there's also the
possibility that the Further Adventures
of Lucifer Morning Star could be
explored outside of liveaction TV though
it was a sarcastic comment at the time
Joe Henderson's suggestion of an
animated offering might be a legitimate
possibility after all the classic 1960s
Batman series got a pair of animated
movie sequels and there's long been talk
of an animated Smallville followup plus
the show featured an animated episode in
season 6 showing that the format is
doable oh that's absurd and his chin
definitely looks like a butt another
possibility with some Merit could be
turning a potential season 7 into a
comic book sequel series bringing the
show back to its source material medium
from Buffy the Vampire Slayer to the
xfiles and Smallville a number of hit
shows have given fans additional seasons
in comic book form in the case of X-Men
the Animated Series the comic book
sequel X-Men 92 even led to a Revival of
the show
itself
he